secret of cooking fantastic food is to
start with great ingredients
the more you know personally about where
your ingredients are from and how they
produce
the better so don't be scared ask lots
of questions
and learn and when it comes to chili's
there's no one better to ask than chili
grower joanna plum
who has been farming chili's from mild
to mind-blown for over 11 years
i eat chillies all the time every single
day
she grows over 60 types on her farm and
really knows her poblanos from a
habaneros
people think that chilis are all about
heat
actually it's about flavour as well
some are sweet some are aromatic
and they can be used in so many
different dishes
when you go shopping and you're looking
for a chili what should you be looking
for
what you want to do is look at the chili
and it needs to be
nice and firm and glossy
generally the bigger the chili the
milder it's going to be
the smaller the chili the hotter and if
it's small and wrinkly like this one
it's going to blow your socks off
another way to tell if a chilli is hot
or not is to split it open and smell it
if it's a super hot chili it'll clear
your sinuses
the heat of a chili comes from an oil
called capsaicin
and that is concentrated mainly at the
top of the chili where the seeds are
now when you're cooking with a chili and
you want the flavor of the chili but not
too much of the heat
start with just using the bottom of it
as you get
closer to the seeds that chili's going
to get hotter
so if you remove the seeds that also
does remove some of the heat
there's thousands of varieties out there
because they cross pollinate
very very easily and that's why the
world's hottest chili
is always changing joanna's right with
over 200 types available
all with different flavors aromas and of
course levels of heat
it's important to buy what you like here
are my top chilis whatever your desired
kick
at the mild end poblano these are great
for stuffing
have a delicate flavor and often used in
mexican dishes
starting to get hot the jalapeno when
they're green they're like spicy bell
pepper the redder they are
the sweeter they are bird's eye where
they really start to pack a punch
long thin and pungent they're great in
thai dishes and are often green or red
and at the top end the habanero these
lantern shaped demons have a delicious
fruity taste
and they're the firecracker of the chili
world another way to
use chilis is to smoke them and to make
chipotle what it is it's just
a mesquite smoked red jalapeno
it smells fantastic you can almost get
that like
smoky bacon sort of flavor out of it
so you would use this in anything that
you would slow cook
so you're eating a chili and it's really
too hot for you
the best way to get rid of that heat is
to drink some milk or a dairy product
like yoghurt
whatever you do don't go for water or
for beer
don't be frightened of trying new types
of chilies in your cooking experimenting
with these amazing fiery beasts
is a great excuse for getting hot-headed
in the kitchen
they give you a natural high much like
when you've been exercising
so your endorphins are released and you
just feel
good chili's make you happy and they're
also an aphrodisiac
to get the seeds out hold it upright and
just rub
the chili between your hands the seeds
are incredibly hot
you're just releasing them from the
inside tapping it down
and then again just a final little rub
now cut the top off and then
just open up and lock
they come out like little miniature
smarties
from there cut the little bottom bit off
amazing next
a great tip for using spare chilis using
string
tie together the stalks then simply hang
in your kitchen in just a few
weeks you'll get your very own dried
chilies great crumbled into dishes for
adding heat on demand
chilies are surprisingly versatile if
you love them in savory dishes
my tip is to try adding them to melty
chocolate ganache for chocolate chilli
truffles
or sprinkled over fresh fruit like mango
or watermelon
a great tip to prevent burning sensitive
skin when working with chilies
to get rid of that spice and that heat
on your fingers a little bit of lemon
squeeze a little bit of lemon juice and
that instantly
gets rid of the heat fresh lemon juice
spice up your drinks for a mexican twist
add a dash of hot chili sauce to beer
or using cocktails to give your drink a
very different sort of cake salad
if you use them confidently they can
really add a new dimension
to the style of cooking but the real
trick is finding that balance of flavors
that really suits you
because that's the most important part
so this is the most amazing sirloin
you can see it's got that wonderful
marble for me the secret behind this
is cooking it quickly season the steaks
generously
salt and pepper push that seasoning
in to the sirloin take the third one out
the fridge literally 20 minutes before
you want to cook them so it gets up to
room temperature they cook more evenly
but more importantly you can actually
season right inside
the steak this little bit of fat down
here season that as well because that
is what we want to roast and get that
really nice and rendered
olive oil in a tablespoon roll that
round
as it starts to smoke in with the steaks
into the pan and lay away
again into the pan and lay away
if you don't hear that noise the minute
those steaks hit the pan
don't put them in so the secret now is
getting that color on the steak
turning it once and once only and
cooking it for two and a half minutes
each side what i want to do is to get
that bit of fat
rendered so it adds a lot more flavor
just hold
the steak down like that and that starts
to melt the fat which makes it
so much more tender there should be no
white fat left anywhere
turn them over really important to have
that steak up to room temperature before
you start cooking it so the inside
is nice and warm so we spend less time
in the pan
and more time cooling down really
important
now two fingers touch
it goes in says rare i'm happy for them
to be rare because by the time i let
them rest
they're going to go back to medium rare
it'll continue cooking
out onto a plate and let them rest
one two
let's get my juices over
don't waste that really important
next the spicy dressing take the seeds
out of a chili to reduce the heat by
rubbing it in your hands
and tapping until the seeds fall out cut
it in half
and just chop it in
garlic and chilli works brilliantly a
quick way of peeling it
get your knife and just slam it down
pops out very very quickly in a little
touch of salt
rub start going around in circles first
you'll see it puring
nice clear that off now we've got the
heat in there from the chilli
and that richness from the garlic two
teaspoons of palm sugar
this is where it starts to have that
nice sweet sour
effect fish sauce
fresh lime this is a simple fresh chili
dressing and it was something i fell in
love with in vietnam
and cambodia because it was just so easy
give that a little mix and dissolve the
sugar
quick taste
wow right vegetables a great fuss-free
way to get super thin ribbons of carrot
is to use a veg peeler
when they're that thin they take the
vinaigrette so much better and radishes
just slice them down at an angle
lovely to give another dimension to the
salad i'm gonna use a banana shallot
they are incredibly mellow very sweet
across just chop up
the shallot and mix that through
want some sweetness in there now little
vine tomatoes
slice them in half tomatoes in
shallot radish carrots and tomatoes
next peel and slice cucumber chopped
spring onions
and shred baby gem lettuce and then
finally
get some fresh mint there's young men so
you don't need to take all those stalks
off all you do is hold the bunch upside
down
and then take it for a little trim
and just chop that once through
you've got that nice minted salad
a couple of tablespoons of dressing
don't flood the cellar with a dressing
we can always add but we can't take it
away now really mix that dressing in
there
make sure all that chili and garlic and
palm sugar
wraps around that salad beautiful
onto the plate the steak's rested it's
now nice and medium rare
a little bit of fat we don't want to
find that in the salad
just slice that off that serves its
purpose
it's kept that steak nice and moist just
slice
going with the grain it's almost like
slicing through butter
and look inside beautiful
pink you slice the beef too thinly then
it goes stone cold
and more importantly all the goodness
runs out of it nice thick
slices get the beef and start
placing it around the salad
take a little teaspoon of your dressing
the rest of your salad
sip that on top we'll finish it off with
some
toasted peanuts peanuts in
now those nuts are really toasted nuts
on get another pan
and just crush once they've cooled down
just run them through with a knife you
can hear how crunchy they are
another texture another taste the salad
and then from there sprinkle
and then finally take that just finish
it with a little
tablespoon of that sauce and there is
one tasty
very well textured spicy beef salad
[Music]
you